and that allows you to stay informed on
the things that the people that are most
important to you care about it's a way
for your name to constantly at the front
but not in a selling salesy kind of way
where you're just asking for somebody to
spend money with you constantly when you
can mix those two together that's when
you build a really successful company
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out onto the world and so to help you on
your journey today we're gonna look at
seven ways that you can be more valuable
and ultimately make more money joy so
the number one rule in business if you
want to make money is you got to provide
value right the more value you provide
the more money you're going to make if
you're looking to make more money you're
stuck you want to pay those bills you
want to upgrade your life you want to
have more financial control of your
future then immediately start thinking
how can I provide more value to the
people around me and today I'm gonna
share with you seven different ways to
do it so the first thing we need to do
is get to know our customers a little
bit better know them a little more
detail their pains their concerns what
they're all about
and so my tip number one is to create
Google News Alerts for the 30 most
important customers and people in your
life and so with the Alerts allow you to
do is anytime there's a new piece of
news that comes out around a certain
topic it'll send you a notification and
that allows you to stay informed on the
things that the people that are most
important to you care about I do this
for the people my personal life I also
do it for my top 30 business connections
that I want to help out as an example
one of the people that I know has Lyme
disease and she's been battling with it
for a long time and I knew zero about
Lyme disease getting into this but when
she told me she had Lyme disease the
very first thing I went when I got home
was I went to Google News Alerts and I
typed in Lyme disease and I subscribed
to Lyme disease and so now once a day
max
get an update of all the different Lyme
disease news topics that are out there
on an ongoing basis and most of the
stuff you know it's just for my
education most stuff I don't end up
sharing but every now and then you get a
fantastic nugget an example there was a
story of an Australian rugby player who
had Lyme disease and was super
debilitating and he used hyperthermia
I think I got that right treatment to
help him get better he was told he'd
never play rugby again and now he's
playing rugby again and he tells his
store in the battle and I thought at
worst this is a uplifting piece that I
can share with this contact of mine I
ended up sharing it with her and says
thank you so much this is really helpful
I had never heard of hyperthermia
treatment Eileen learned of hypothermia
treatment and so now she's adding it to
her list of things that she's going to
be researching and so if you know one or
two or three little things about the
people that you want to connect with
things that are interesting to them one
always put their name always always
always always always put their name
because anytime somebody comes up in the
news you will know about it and it's a
fantastic way to reach out to say hey I
saw you were mentioned in that USA Today
article or I saw you featured on Yahoo
story or whatever it is and it's just a
great way to stay in touch and be be top
of mind for people but if you know one
or two or three things about them that
they really care about like Lyme disease
or specific habit or hobby or something
else that's really on their mind and you
keep feeding them information of MU
trending things that are happening in
that field it's a fantastic way to add
more value and stay top of mind with the
relationship because you want them
thinking about you so they will buy more
from you and they will tell their
friends about you as well
[Music]
way number two is follow them in social
media all of your most important clients
I would even try to extend this to all
of your clients if possible depending on
how many people you're serving you want
to follow them on all the major social
media channels if they have a youtube
channel you want to follow them if
they're on Twitter your their LinkedIn
your their Instagram you're there and
you're just to start paying attention to
what they're posting what you're looking
for is just a little more insight into
who this person is and what they care
about and opportunities that may allow
you to further enhance the relationship
okay some point maybe my contact posts
on Twitter that she has a Lyme disease
right and that teaches me a little bit
and that information can funnel into
your Google News Alerts to get more
information on how to help that person
out it also just teaches you a little
bit more about what they care about and
their favorite pastimes hobbies places
to eat example I have a meeting with a
potential big client and I found who the
contact person was on Twitter and kind
of stalked her a little bit I didn't I
didn't I didn't respond to anything she
wrote but she said in one of her tweets
that she loves the cookies at little
Nikki's so look up what the heck is
little Nikki's and it turns out is this
little coffee shop right down the street
from where she is and so when I went to
go meet her for the first time it was
her and her team I went a little Nicky's
five minutes before going in and I
bought up all of their cookies 50
different kinds of cookies and I brought
it as a gift he said hey here's his
local bake shop I didn't say I'm found
you on twitter or in stalked you
I said hey here's some cookies that I
brought along from my little Nicky's I
love little Nicky's right so it's a
great icebreaker right from the
beginning so the more you know
information is power the more
information you have on the people who
you're dealing business with and the
more ways you have the stay top of mind
not with a sales pitch not are you ready
to buy my book now are you ready to buy
some merch now right it's not a sales
pitch it's a genuine connection with
something that they actually care about
and the more you can stay top of mind
like that the more they're going to want
to buy from you the more they're gonna
want to refer to you it's sometimes hard
to pull out information in the
conversation that's why if you're
following them on social media it's a
lot easier to get to know a little bit
more about them not everybody's gonna
post on social but the ones who do you
want to keep on top of what they are
posting
[Music]
way number three is quarterly
introductions from your list of the 30
most important people in your business I
would start looking one Supporter at
least at trying to make introductions to
other people in your network that might
serve them case in point example i have
a youtube friend of mine who's you know
million plus subscriber is looking to
get a book deal i introduced him to my
publisher my publisher is looking for a
certain criteria for people to do deals
with and so it's a way for the publisher
and it's a win for my friend the
youtuber and everybody's thinking about
me in that process now i don't benefit
financially immediately from that
transaction happening but both of them
are gonna have my name on the tip of
their tongue when they look for new
opportunities because i continue to
provide value to them and so if there's
somebody who i haven't helped in a while
once a quarter is kind of the threshold
that i look at i think about that person
I try to think okay who can I introduce
this person to that might be valuable
for all parties involved and so whether
you for me it's just like an Excel
spreadsheet whether you keep it an Excel
spreadsheet or you put it somewhere else
just some kind of way to keep on top of
the people who you're helping out once a
quarter minimum try to make a connection
to somebody else in your network that
can provide value to them way number
four is social media amplification so if
you're following them on social and you
know what's important to them what I'm
doing now is keeping an eye on what are
some of the things that they are trying
to actively promote whether it's their
book a campaign a cause some celebration
that they want to put out and just
amplifying it one is just responding to
people and saying hey congrats in a new
book that's awesome
and to is sharing it with your audience
you don't even have to have a massive
audience for this to make an impact
because up for a lot of these people
they're posting stuff and nobody
interacts with them zero right like zero
likes especially the the promotional
stuff like hey guys check out my new
book or hey check out this new thing
that I just created like promo stuff
nobody ever interacts with it so you're
gonna be the only one who's interacting
and if you say something like hey
Congrats it's awesome looking forward to
reading the copy of it or you retweet it
to your audience or whatever the the
application is it really makes you stand
out because when they post something up
this is zero engagement and you
the only one doing something about it I
did this a lot with the honest company
as a quick example when I was writing my
book your one word the honest company's
featured in there and Christopher
Gavigan is the co-founder and he would
be posting stuff on Twitter all the time
and I would find a way to try to say
great article great contribution retweet
something that he was saying it wasn't
it wasn't super heavy hand it wasn't
like four times a day I'm tweeting him
but whenever he had something that
seemed to really matter to him a
powerful opinion a new promotion
something that you could tell is
something that really connected with him
was meaningful to him I would engage
with it and he would always always
always write back to say Evan thank you
so much for the amplification and reach
I really really appreciate it and so
finding the platforms where they are at
and then engaging especially the things
that they care about and helping spread
the message whether it goes to an
audience of a million people that you
have or whether you have ten followers
just the fact that you are willing to
share it and engage with it makes you
stand out make sure you're adding more
value to the relationship and they are
going to think about you for future
opportunities
[Music]
wait number five is build products
around problems so part of the reason
why we're listening to our customers on
social is to get a sense of what they
care about their opinions what they're
up to and finding ways to engage and
this is all just trying to stay top of
mind the top of mind comes in handy
because they're thinking about you
that's gonna lead the business on a
regular basis but what you also want to
do a faster way to drive business
results is listen to the problems that
they have what are they complaining
about what are they upset about what are
they frustrated about what are they
sharing and again not everybody's gonna
share all over social media but it's
surprising how much people actually do
share their opinions on social and
especially about what frustrates them
for a lot of people they get angry at a
company or a certain process and the
first thing you do is they go to social
and they make a video or they send a
tweet or they they do something online
and so if you see problems that you can
potentially solve then that becomes a
great opportunity for you now a lot of
things they complain about may not be
related they may be upset at how warm
their Starbucks drink was right like
maybe that's not your industry if you're
selling a b2b SAS service but if there's
anything related to what it is that you
do it's an opportunity to create a new
product and if they're talking at all
about
her feedback coming in so now not just
social but people are writing in to say
hey I love your shoe but it I have this
kind of problem or I love your software
but if it had this feature be really
helpful you want to decide as much as
possible the new features that you are
launching a new product and service that
you were coming out with based off of
the feedback from actual customers who
are paying you to use it it always is a
combination of what you love what you
think is missing what you think is
needed your vision where you're going
that plus what the customer wants the
frustrations the pain points the desires
it demands when you can mix those two
together that's when you build a really
successful company and so the first part
of just the intuition just you where you
think the markets going and paying
attention what you want to create but
the second part is really practical its
tangible its fostering the relationships
with your clients asking their genuine
feedback on how to make things better
and then using it to actually make your
products and services better so you
always want to build your new products
and services around the problems of your
customers
[Music]
all right the six way is to share
industry data this one I really really
really really really love and basically
what it involves is while you are
learning about how your industry works
about the trends that are happening if
you know that there's something you're
working on there could be a value of
interest to your clients
then you want to share that it shows off
your thought leadership it shows off
that you're thinking about them and that
you care about their business more than
just the transaction that you just went
through recently so example one of the
things that I do when I work with my
corporate clients so I have all these
brands who are trying to work with me to
help market entrepreneurship and get
their message out everything that I'm
testing in the entrepreneur community in
the YouTube algorithm and the social
media world whatever I learn to the new
that I found really works after lots of
testing that I'll share it with some
select people brand clients other
youtubers close contacts and saying guys
this is really really helping me this is
really exploding my business whether
it's on the YouTube side again or a now
isn't building on my Instagram channel
or just topics at entrepreneurs care
about and every quarter at least I try
to share a new insight of something that
I am learning with these closest people
in mine
work because now they see me as an
indispensable asset because I'm over
delivering like crazy because I'm doing
way more than just what I was hired to
do as a client or as a partner and so
whenever you are testing something new
you know you should be playing on the
leading edge of your industry if you're
just doing what everybody else is doing
you don't have a chance of being a
really successful business right you
need to be playing at the edge and that
means you're testing you're tweaking
you're trying new things and as you
discover those things that work then you
want to share with those select people
in your network you could decide the
blast it out and be a thought leader and
make a youtube video about it and go go
big but this is really what I want you
to make more money from your clients I
want you to be indispensable I want you
to be able to triple your prices because
you're bringing so much insane value to
the people who are in your network and
so sharing industry data sharing best
practices that you have come up with and
educating your clients on that to show
that you care about the end result for
them you should care about their
business growing not just about them
spending X amount of dollars with you
sharing that industry data is really
helpful and goes a long way to building
that relationship up and my number seven
way to be more valuable to your clients
and ultimately make more money is to
celebrate milestones one of the things
that I have loved to do over the past
couple years of my youtube channel is
for my contacts who are passing
milestones on YouTube I'll make a
celebration video and so we did it for
Gary Vee I did it for Cruz Markham and
you did it for Antonio Centeno real men
real style did it for a bunch of people
where we noticed that they're about to
hit a milestone usually around 1 million
subscribers is what we do it for but
we've done it around half a million and
smaller numbers too and I would reach
out to everybody who are super fans of
them so go to their recent videos see
who's commenting a lot a lot a lot a lot
a lot and about a month before we think
they're gonna hit the target we start
reaching out to them and say hey I'm
making a surprise video for Gary Vee
about hitting the million subscribers I
would love it if you can make a quick
video like 10 to 15 seconds of how
Gary's impacted your life and send it to
me and so we would over the next month
collect all of these short 10 to 15
second testimonials of thoughts and
praise from different people
and then collect it and put it together
into one video that then I would share
once they passed a million I'd have my
own message say hey Gary
love your content Congrats great work
and I contacted some of your superfans
and they all have a message for you and
then just like van Bam Bam Bam Bam
sitting at all the value from all of the
fans and what it lets all these new
people know about you right like it's a
side benefit of of marketing you're
putting this thing together well who is
this guy who was asking me to make it
this 10 to 15 second video so now you
have more people on your radar but to
more importantly when you're giving that
video to that person it really makes it
stand out everybody that I've made this
kind of video for has said this is above
and beyond I'm so appreciative thank you
so much it means a lot to me it's a way
for your name to constantly at the front
but not in a selling salesy kind of way
where you're just asking for somebody to
spend money with you constantly and so
it's looking for those opportunities now
you can do it around hitting a
subscriber count' on on any of the
social media platforms it could be
around them receiving some kind of award
it could be because you've followed them
on Twitter or on Google news alerts and
you recognize that they won some kind of
prize that they hit some kind of
milestone or they promoting something
new all of those things just looking for
ways to celebrate look for ways to
celebrate milestones that they are going
after that are meaningful to them in
their business and saying hey Congrats I
believe in you I really appreciate the
work that you're doing and bonus if you
can bring some of their superfans along
for the ride as well so those are my
thoughts on the 7 ways to bring more
value to your clients and ultimately
make more money I would love to know
which one resonated the most with you
what are you going to apply immediately
which strategy are you gonna launch
right now for your contacts and your
business leave it down in the comments
below did I miss an 8 9 10 that you want
to add to the list put it down below
looking forward to hearing your thoughts
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon raise your standard apple at the
core it's core value
is that we believe that people with
passion can change the way people not
one drop of myself work depends on your
that's something sue me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual Clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details